bonjour installez-vous Jean-Pierre
merci beaucoup d'être notre invité ce
matin ancien Premier ministre président
de l'ongle d'or pour la paix auteur de
ce livre ne sortons pas de l'histoire
c'est aux éditions Michel Lafon va
évidemment en parler Jean-Pierre
Raffarin il y a un an jour pour jour
Vladimir Poutine déclencher donc la
guerre en Ukraine est-ce que vous
attendiez à une guerre qui dure aussi
longtemps
je crois que ça les faite pour durer
cette guerre parce que
d'une part Poutine à sans doute une
stratégie
de d'user la population
ukrainienne et puis d'autre part les
Américains ne t'ont pas encore pris
complètement leur rôle politique pour le
moment les Américains soutiennent comme
nous tous nous soutenons l'Ukraine mais
en fait Poutine pour sortir de cette
guerre vaudra une discussion avec Biden
car l'adversaire de Poutine c'est
d'abord les États-Unis donc on voit pas
encore aujourd'hui
Maiden et Poutine capable de se
rencontrer et de commencer à bâtir un
plan de paix donc hélas je crains que ça
puisse durer et ça ce qui est très grave
c'est que le peuple ukrainien et la
première victime de cette stratégie mais
je pense que l'oignon européenne
peut-être la deuxième victime parce que
nous avons beaucoup de conséquences
négatives de cette guerre sur nos
propres affaires en Europe et c'est ce
que vous dites dans votre livre et on va
en parler mais vous dites le véritable
ennemi finalement de Vladimir Poutine ce
sont les États-Unis plus que l'Ukraine
c'est ça je pense que pour Poutine
l'interlocuteur c'est byeden et donc
c'est avec Biden qui voudra sortir la
pêche je pense que c'est comme ça qu'il
voit les choses et donc c'est c'est
difficile parce que pour le moment c'est
qui qui conduit la guerre et Poutine qui
voudrait négocier avec bayden donc c'est
une difficulté qu'il faudra résoudre
cette semaine justement on a entendu les
deux hommes en Joe Biden très ferme
envers la Russie et Vladimir Poutine lui
aussi très virulent envers les
Occidentaux envers les États-Unis est-ce
que ça laisse craindre une nouvelle
escalade je pense que on a une station
extrêmement dangereuse parce que il y a
deux compétitions simultanées la
compétition entre les États-Unis et la
Russie vraiment qui est une compétition
sur le terrain ukrainien et qui est une
compétition extrêmement vive et
terriblement meurtrière et puis il y a
la compétition entre la Chine et les
États-Unis donc au fond il y a là une un
monde extrêmement dangereux moi ça fait
50 ans que je fais de la vie publique la
vie politique je n'ai jamais vu le monde
aussi dangereux qu'aujourd'hui une
étincelle peut conduire au drame et
d'ailleurs dans votre livre vous
rappelez les propos du pape François il
y a quelques mois sur la troisième qui
qualifie cette guerre mondiale dans une
graine pardon de 3e guerre mondiale et
vous dites il a raison je pense qu'il a
raison parce qu'on font le
potentiellement n'est pas aujourd'hui à
la guerre mondiale mais le potentielle
existe on voit la Chine est pas très
loin du soutien avec la Russie les
États-Unis sont à fond avec l'Ukraine et
nous européen on commence à être
étranglé par cette guerre donc il y a
une situation qui va devenir
insupportable et donc elle sera très
dangereuse mais pour vous cette guerre
Russie-Ukraine c'est finalement une
guerre par procuration entre la Chine et
les États-Unis non c'est pas une guerre
par contre il s'agit du peuple ukrainien
du territoire ukrainien donc les
Ukrainiens sont en première ligne mais
sans le soutien des États-Unis il n'y
aurait pas guerre aujourd'hui sans le
soutien des Européens non plus et donc
il est clair que l'offensive Poutine
aurait tout de suite rasé l'Ukraine donc
c'est cette réaction de l'Occident qui a
permis cette résistance mais aujourd'hui
le leader qui conduit cette guerre
aujourd'hui c'est
Poutine sans doute pas discuter
aujourd'hui avec zenenski puisque le
matériel est fourni par les Occidentaux
Poutine dans la tête de vouloir négocier
avec les Occidentaux non seulement sur
le territoire ukrainien mais aussi sur
l'équilibre du monde et qui peut être la
puissance de négociation déjà est-ce que
l'issue de ce conflit pour vous peut
passer par une négociation je pense qu'à
un moment ou un autre son pour n'ira par
la négociation aujourd'hui zen esquive
construire un rapport de force qui lui
est favorable donc il veut bien les
négociations à condition d'avoir un
rapport de force sur le terrain
favorable donc le moment viendra je
pense pour cette négociation mais là
c'est Biden moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec les États-Unis sur un certain
nombre de choses aujourd'hui mais je
reconnais bien volontiers que Biden a
une expérience internationale assez
exemplaire il a été vice-président
d'Obama il connaît bien si Jean Ping il
connaît bien Poutine il connaît bien ce
monde là donc je c'est plutôt confiance
pour choisir le bon moment pour engager
des négociations donc notamment pas à
faire aux Etats-Unis comme la période
Trump où on avait l'improvisation
quotidienne là il y a de la stratégie
parce que vous en parlez entre Chine
Etats-Unis on a vu cette semaine les
Américains qui accusent les Chinois de
vouloir livrer des armes à la Russie les
Chinois qui démontent qu'est-ce qu'il
faut voir dans ces accusations
réciproques je pense qu'on ne sait
l'escalade entre la Chine et les
États-Unis vous savez c'est assez
classique on a appelé ça le piège de
tussidie c'est qu'en Sparte faisait la
guerre avec Athènes ou quand Rome
faisait la guerre avec Carthage c'est le
numéro 1 qui veut pas voir la montée du
numéro 2 et le numéro 2 qui se verrait
bien à la place du numéro 1 donc la
Chine et les États-Unis c'est exactement
ça mais on était dans une guerre qui
était une guerre commerciale de tarifs
je dois dire qui a été les boycottes des
Jeux olympiques mais là maintenant c'est
une course militaire il y a l'affaire
Taïwan qui est une affaire très
difficile et donc on est dans une
situation où l'escalade devient très
dangereuse mais on voit quand même dans
les initiatives chinoises qu'ils sont un
peu gênés par cette guerre au fond il
n'aime pas être isolé les chinois ils
ont une prétention mondiale donc Poutine
on le sent quand même est assez mal vu
par un grand nombre de pays aujourd'hui
très mal vu par exemple même si les
abstentions à l'ONU sont nombreuses dans
sa faveur donc je crois que vraiment que
les chinois sont un peu gênés par la
tournure que pensait bien et surtout
vous voyez ils mettent des barrières
quant à l'usage du nucléaire donc pour
le moment je pense que les chinois sont
assez gênés mais c'est c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être très très prudent parce
que je ne crois pas que les Chinois
feraient la guerre pour l'Ukraine je ne
crois pas qu'ils soutiendrait la Russie
dans ce contexte
vous ne croyez pas des livraisons
d'armes chinoises pour les Russes
je ne sais pas mais je ne les vois pas
entrer stratégiquement dans une guerre
ils ont un projet de guerre ces projets
Taïwan ça faut pas se tromper sur Taïwan
ils seront prêts à faire la guerre mais
pour les autres sujets je ne le crois
pas sur ces sujets là c'est pour ça que
dans mon livre j'insiste sur la
dangerosité du système et que si
l'Europe ne fait pas une réaction si
l'Europe ne se défend pas on va être
écrasé voir on va disparaître d'ailleurs
il y a deux façons de disparaître ça
peut être la guerre entre la Chine et
les États-Unis mais ça peut être
l'entendre oui c'est il s'entendront sur
notre dos on va venir parce que c'est
une phrase assez marquante de votre
livre mais un dernier mot sur la Chine
puisque la Chine s'est tenu à exposer à
la Russie sa vision pour le règlement
politique du conflit et le gouvernement
chinois a appelé il y a quelques heures
la Russie et l'Ukraine à reprendre le
dialogue est-ce que la Chine peut être
une clé de résolution du coup je pense
que la Chine c'est sans doute l'un des
pays sans doute le seul vraiment
puissant qui peut avoir une influence
sur Poutine donc il peut le mettre à la
table des négociations pour le moment il
y avait un point qui était important que
les Chinois ont développé c'est-à-dire
non au à l'usage du nucléaire et
maintenant c'est autour de la table donc
je pense que les Chinois peuvent pousser
dans cette direction mais vous savez la
machine
Poutine en tout cas c'est les seuls qui
peut écouter donc dans cette dans
aujourd'hui d'autoritarisme c'est le
seul qui peuvent qui peuvent vraiment
écouter je pense que au fond les Chinois
ce qui est dangereux aujourd'hui c'est
que jusqu'à maintenant avant les
derniers événements les Chinois étaient
assez prévisibles et là on les a vu
quand on a vu cette stratégie covid
changer du jour au lendemain là on a le
sentiment que la Chine est plus
imprévisible et donc d'une certaine
manière plus dangereux quand on est
prévisible on est moins dangereux que
quand on est imprévisible donc
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je pense que de
toute façon pour nous le risque la
question majeure c'est Taïwan saïwan ils
veulent l'Empire l'unité c'est très
important quand vous demandez un chinois
quel est l'homme politique qui a le plus
raté son rôle dans l'histoire il vous
disent Gorbatchev qui a éclaté l'Empire
russe et donc ils veulent pas en éclater
l'empire chinois donc Taïwan pour eux
dans l'empire donc il faut essayer de
protéger tes watts ça c'est leur vision
ils sont prêtes aller à la bataille sur
ce sujet donc nous nous avons des
négociations à faire nous avons des
discussions à faire mais c'est là le
foyer de gain je pense que c'est le
sujet de majeur de la guerre avec les
Chinois c'est pas un sujet
ukrainien qui aujourd'hui est dominant
de mon point de vue alors justement dans
votre livre vous dites que l'Union
européenne est prise en tenaille entre
la Chine et les États-Unis avec cette
phrase si la Chine et les États-Unis ne
s'entend pas au risque la grande guerre
s'il s'entendent nos risques qu'on notre
sortie de l'histoire l'Union européenne
est perdante à tous les coups je pense
que pas forcément à tous les coups si
elle est capable de construire sa
souveraineté si elle est capable
d'affirmer un leadership si elle se
donne un avenir elle peut exister mais
elle existera dans un rapport de force
ce sont pas des bisounours c'est un
rapport de force et s'il y a un rapport
de force équilibré entre la Chine et les
élus ils vont passer des îles ils vont
avoir des accords sur les puces sur
toutes l'alimentation technologique
nécessaire cela surveillance des réseaux
sur tout ça et nous on sera piloté par
ces deux puissances organisées donc il
nous faut une souveraineté et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'état d'esprit des
opinions publiques voire des dirigeants
en Europe c'est pas la conscience de la
gravité la gravité c'est qu'on va
disparaître de l'histoire si on n'est
pas des leaders sur un certain nombre de
sujets si on n'a pas une stratégie donc
pour moi il y a une raison de l'Europe
qu'il faudrait affirmer c'est
l'équilibre et la paix parce que
aujourd'hui les autres puissances sont
moins bien placé que nous nous on a
surmonté la honte on a surmonté
l'horreur du nazisme on a on a construit
l'amitié avec les Allemands ce que les
Chinois et les Japonais n'ont pas fait
par exemple donc on a ce message de paix
et d'équilibre mais derrière il faut
qu'on ait une stratégie en quoi pouvons
être nous les meilleurs moi je pense
qu'on peut être les meilleurs dans
l'application de l'accord de Paris dans
la planétisation ce qui est nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que la planète est
devenue un objet politique quand j'ai
commencé la politique dans mon poète ou
natal il y a la planète n'est pas du
tout un sujet politique on parlait de la
conquête spatiale mais la planète n'est
pas sujet aujourd'hui les jeunes de
Shanghai les jeunes de Bangalore les
jeunes de San Francisco les gens de
Chasseneuil-du-Poitou sortent dans la
rue pour défendre la planète et donc là
il y a quelque chose qui est très il y a
un consensus dans les sociétés et
notamment dans la jeunesse donc je pense
que l'Europe doit être la force qui va
préparer un avenir pour la planète
c'est-à-dire un avenir pour l'humanité
c'est la nouvelle humanité il faut qu'on
ait une strat on a des sujets je pense
qu'il faut bien voir comment on sort de
cette tenaille entre la Chine et les
États-Unis pour moi il nous faut un
sujet majeur avec les Américains c'est
nous sommes la fraternité en démocratie
nous avons à améliorer nos systèmes
démocratiques ensemble non seulement
avec les Américains mais aussi avec les
démocraties de l'Est je pense au Japon à
la Corée du Sud avec les démocraties
africaines avec les démocraties
sud-américaine ça on a un dossier avec
les américains puis on a un dossier avec
les Chinois qui est le développement de
l'Afrique l'Afrique a besoin de moyens
pour un développement de l'Afrique pour
les Africains et ça les Chinois ont ses
moyens mais on voit bien que les Chinois
ont des problèmes de pratique et je
dirais d'intégration au territoire donc
un trilogue entre la Chine l'Europe et
l'Afrique permettrait sans doute ce plan
donc à mon avis on peut faire un plan
pour l'Afrique ma conviction de base
c'est que nous européens nous ne serons
pas heureux si l'Afrique n'est pas
heureuse donc on est lié à cette
stratégie de développement de l'Afrique
pour les Africains ça peut se faire avec
les Chinois peut-être aussi avec les
Indiens avec les Japonais il faut avoir
cette stratégie là et donc si on avait
ces deux pôles d'une part un accord sur
la fraternité en démocratie avec les
Américains et d'autre part un problème
un projet de développement de l'Afrique
avec les Chinois on pourrait passer
entre les deux sans perdre notre
souveraineté je dirais à la de Gaulle
pour ça il faut qu'on soit champion de
quelque chose il faut qu'on soit
champion de la défense de la planète et
ça ça demande l'implication de la Porte
de Paris ça demande des sujets
importants je vois que ce matin dans
l'actualité madame board annonce un plan
ferroviaire j'en parle dans mon livre ça
paraît une priorité c'est le genre de
sujet qui est conforme à la défense de
la planète et qui en même temps est
conforme à la cohésion territoriale à la
cohésion sociale et donc là je crois
qu'on est dans la bonne direction c'est
ce qu'il faut faire des sujets mais il
faut pas 36 pour moi c'est le nucléaire
et le ferroviaire ces deux sujets plan à
30 ans c'est le sujet qui doit mobiliser
l'investissement public mais est-ce que
le bilan de c'est un angle guerre en
Ukraine c'est pas aussi un renforcement
de l'Union européenne est-ce que c'est
pas renforcé affirmer modifier
personnellement je ne le crois pas je
suis préoccupé par la relation
franco-allemande qui se détériore si
vous voulez quand les peuples européens
quand les peuples européens ont peur ils
se tournent vers les États-Unis or pour
avoir notre souveraineté il nous faut
une défense commune il nous faut une
protection commune or aujourd'hui la
moitié de l'Europe veut la protection
des États-Unis il y a 2 ans le président
disait l'OTAN est en mort cérébrale
aujourd'hui tout le monde va adhérer le
temps donc on voit bien que on entre
sous la protection des Américains mais
on sait bien qu'avec les américains ils
nous veulent comme allier misez moins
mieux nous avoir encore comme aligné
donc nous on veut pas être aligné on
respecte les Américains on est proche de
sur le plan politique on n'est pas
proche de la Chine évidemment sur le
plan politique on veut pas être
communiste et de eux d'ailleurs ne veut
pas être démocrates donc on a des
divergences clairs qui sont sur ce côté
mais avec les États-Unis on veut qu'ils
acceptent l'idée de l'indépendance de
l'Europe c'est indépendance européenne
c'est notre seul issus si on n'est pas
indé on sera dévoré Emmanuel Macron ce
matin appelle à la victoire de l'Ukraine
dit que la France est aux côtés des
Ukrainiens la semaine dernière à Munich
il a dit que la Russie ne peut ni ne
doit gagner cette guerre puis dans
l'avion quelques heures plus tard il a
dit qu'il ne fallait pas écraser la
Russie est-ce que vous comprenez cette
position bien sûr que je comprends cette
position parce que de toute façon la
Russie a tout voisin donc on n'aura pas
de paix à terme si on n'a pas un accord
avec le voisin le moment venu donc je
comprends bien qu'il faut gagner la
guerre en Ukraine pourquoi pour que dans
la négociation le rapport de force de
l'Ukraine soit favorable donc il faut
aller dans cette direction mais il faut
bien se dire qu'à un moment ou un autre
il nous faudra quelque chose qui
ressemble à la conférence et le sinki en
75 c'est-à-dire un moment où on discute
de l'Est de l'Europe l'Europe ne pourra
pas se développer s'il y a pas la paix à
sonneste donc on est obligé de discuter
avec le voisin et donc il faut pas
transformer cette guerre de l'Ukraine à
la Russie entre une guerre entre
l'Europe et la Russie il faudra bien un
moment ou un autre pouvoir gérer cette
frontière est de l'Europe donc je crois
que les deux idées sont difficiles le en
même temps est toujours compliqué mais
il faut un rapport de force favorable à
l'Ukraine nous sommes dans le camp de
l'Ukraine nous sommes vraiment de cœur
et de force avec le peuple ukrainien qui
est agressé dans cette affaire donc il y
a pas d'ambiguïté mais nous voyons bien
que à terme on a une portée de vue
naturellement qui est un peu plus longue
parce qu'on n'est pas exposé à la guerre
et où toutes les douleurs immédiates
mais dans cette portée de vue il faudra
bien que à notre frontière laisse on est
une citation pacifiée il va falloir
accorder des garanties de sécurité à la
Russie pour avoir des de la paix en
Europe une Europe stable ça je pense que
ça a été pendant très longtemps la clé
on avait pris des engagements pour qu'il
n'y ait pas un déploiement de force à la
frontière russe donc il y avait cette
zone tampon dont on parie autrefois donc
je pense qu'il faudra réfléchir à une
situation dans laquelle la Russie
trouvera des éléments de sécurité la
paix passe par la conscience de la
sécurité et la l'organisation de la
sécurité si la Russie est en situation
dangereuse elle ne fera pas la paix on
va revenir un sujet de politique
intérieure Jean-Pierre Raffarin le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron invoque souvent l'exemple de nos
voisins européens pour justifier la
réforme des retraites est-ce que ne pas
décaler cette âge ça a fait le virer la
France au sein de l'Union européenne
pour vous je crois que de toute façon il
faut faire cette réforme parce que on
voit bien que il y a un problème de
financement mais surtout on a une
stratégie qui est la stratégie de la
répartition est-ce qu'on défend cette
stratégie ou est-ce qu'on l'abandonne
alors je vois bien que tout le monde est
prêt à détruire ce système mais par quoi
on le remplace et comment on va
organiser les choses on a bien vu que la
réforme à points c'était extrêmement
difficile ça a pas été possible et je
vois bien qu'à côté de ça les produits
financiers vont chercher à s'imposer et
donc on va aller vers la capitalisation
c'est assez incroyable de voir je pense
à un certain nombre de jeunes qui sont
protégés dans l'avenir par la
répartition sont aujourd'hui aussi et ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est le
système qu'on voit à peu près partout
dans le monde se développer que le
système de la capitalisation
et donc là je pense le modèle français
on a un modèle français qui est vraiment
à nous on a une sécurité sociale pour la
maladie on a la répartition pour les
retraites on a des interventions de
l'État pour notre protection sociale et
donc il faut être très attaché à ça et
je pense que ce sont ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin qui aujourd'hui sont
sollicités pour manifester le plus il
faut sauver ce système qui est un
système social de la répartition
qui est mise en place je pense que le
système para répartition qui est mis en
péril garde évidemment je vois bien que
le système de capitalisation va
s'imposer quand je vois que un certain
nombre de gens la France insoumise
attaquent les riches et tout ça les
riches ils auront pas de problème pour
la capitalisation c'est c'est pas eux
qui vont défendre la répartition donc
eux ils auront pas de problème pour
avoir des produits financiers pour leur
retraite le problème aujourd'hui c'est
ceux qui n'ont pas de produits
financiers et cela il faut les aider par
la répartition lorsque vous étiez à
Matignon vous avez réussi vous à faire
une réforme des retraites ça a été salué
par Emmanuel Macron puisque il y a
quelques jours il vous a élevé au plus
en rang de la au plus grand grade aura
de plus élevé de la Légion d'Honneur
vous l'avez vu on voit cette photo
est-ce que vous lui avez des données des
conseils pour réussir sa réforme de
retraite on a on a discuté j'ai pas
donné de conseils parce que d'abord
maintenant on est dans la phase
politique c'était au départ dans la
phase sociale qu'on aurait pu discuter
mais une fois qu'on a fini cette phase
sociale de négociation et qu'on va on a
on est au Parlement aujourd'hui on va
aller au Sénat c'est une affaire de
discussion parlementaire de respect du
Parlement de discussion avec des
amendements donc ce qu'on est dans un
Adventure très très politique donc là et
maintenant il faut écouter les uns les
autres essayer de construire une
majorité mais disons que moi ce que la
grande différence en 2003 il y a deux
différences très importantes que pour
Emmanuel la première c'est que nous
n'avions pas discuté avec Jacques Chirac
sur la réforme des retraites avec les
partenaires sociaux seuls on avait
discuté sur l'agenda social il y avait
trois réformes l'assurance maladie la
décentralisation et les retraites là
CFDT nous a demandé de mettre les
intermittents du spectacle donc nous
avons fait un deal politique sur les
quatre
donc Emmanuel Macron il paye son manque
d'ancrage local je pense que c'est un
dans le débat actuel je pense que ça
manque et je crois que dans la 5e
République on a besoin d'un parti
Giscard n'était pas quand même un
débutant il a créé l'UDF Chirac non plus
il a créé l'UMP ils ont créé des
structures très puissantes donc il faut
une structure pour protéger le président
le président est trop seul souvent on a
on a la chance d'avoir le plus jeune le
plus expérimenté ce qui est très rare en
politique d'être à la fois jeune
expérimenté mais il faut protéger et ça
c'est un parti qui le fait et puis c'est
des forces au Parlement etc je compte
beaucoup sur le Sénat dans le dans ce
débat sur sa sagesse sur les
responsables de la majorité sénatoriale
pour d'abord donner aux Français une
image du parlementaire qui est de plus
responsable et et puis aussi trouver des
solutions pour ce sujet et surtout pour
la fin du week-end mais justement vous
connaissez bien vous le Parlement quel
regard vous avez porté sur les débats
qui se sont déroulés à l'Assemblée c'est
de la déconstruction permanente donc on
voit bien que c'est une idéologie
politique il faut construire donc c'est
la table rase il y a un moment ou un
autre faut casser les systèmes pour
supposer
utopie vouloir les reconstruire donc moi
je suis à réformateur je ne suis pas un
déconstructeur je suis constructif et
donc je pense que c'est ça le rôle du
Parlement j'ai confiance en général
Larcher en Bruno retailleau-philippe sa
tante de leader du Sénat pour montrer
cette phrase que on veut être
constructive exigeant et avoir ses
propres positions mais je dirais très
franchement en lançant un appel à mes
amis sénateurs il y a pas que les
retraites on a 4 ans pour éviter Madame
Le Pen on a quatre ans pour lequel il
nous faut un choc réformateur il nous
faut un certain initiative et ça ça ne
se fera pas sans Sénat on est dans une
situation politique dans laquelle
aujourd'hui la majorité a besoin du
Sénat et le Sénat à toutes les capacités
pour participer pour prendre des
initiatives pour faire en sorte que ce
quinquennat soit un quinquennat qui
puisse changer la donne là où nous avons
travaillé main dans la main avec
Emmanuel Macron je pense que le Sénat
doit être constructif je pense qu'il
doit exister de travailler dans le main
dans la main et pour travailler la main
il faut que les deux parties soient
d'accord je ne sais pas ce que peut
penser Emmanuel Macron donc c'est à eux
de discuter mais ce que je vois c'est
que dans la donne politique actuelle
quel est le point solide quel est le
point fort quel est le point responsable
quel est le point où il y a de la
compétence politique mais aussi
technique administrative c'est le Sénat
donc aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que nous
devons-nous besoin on a besoin de
réforme très significative une meilleure
démocratie politique une meilleure
démocratie sociale une réforme de
l'élection des syndicats on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'on a très peu de
syndicalisations on a besoin de syndicat
fort on a des lois de 45 qui règne notre
système électoral syndicat ça ne marche
pas dans la dans la dans la
décentralisation on a des choses à
améliorer fortement donc on a une
démocratie à revitaliser il y a toutes
les idées il y a toutes les stratégies
majorité avec les républicains je pense
que c'est la seule façon que nous avons
un moment ou un autre mais ça ça veut
dire qu'il faut respecter les uns les
autres qu'il faut voir leurs conditions
qu'il faut voir les projets communs mais
si on veut avancer aujourd'hui
je ne pense pas une dissolution
règlerait quoi que ce soit parce qu'au
fond on aurait peut-être un tiers de
rassemblement national un tiers de nupes
et la France rencontre moins un
gouvernable moi un gouvernable pardon et
donc la solution aujourd'hui je pense
que elle est dans un rôle du Sénat
important qui prend ses responsabilités
qui a ses exigences mais qui assume
squash ce serait très bien parce que
depuis le temps qu'on attend que la
qualité sénatoriale éclate aux yeux des
Français puisqu'on font c'est toujours
l'assemblée qui prend le débat
démocratique d'une certaine en dominant
là c'est le Sénat par sa sagesse par sa
responsabilité qui peut dominer merci
Jean-Pierre Raffarin merci à vous
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin et je
rappelle votre livre ne sortons pas de
l'histoire c'est aux éditions Michel
Lafont merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité on continue cette édition
spéciale un an de guerre en Ukraine